George and Barbara Bush celebrated their
73rd wedding anniversary in January mrs.
Bush said keeping a sense of humor was
the secret to their enduring marriage
Jim Axelrod is here with their love
story which lasted more than
three-quarters of a century Jim good
morning good morning George Herbert
Walker Bush and Barbara Pierce met in
1941 at a school dance he was 17 she was
just 16 he told a friend she was the
most beautiful girl on the dance floor
Barbara Bush was just 19 when she
married her Navy pilot home on leave
from World War two I married the first
man I ever kissed Barbara Bush used to
say when I tell this to my children they
just about throw up and while they did
their best to keep pace with modern life
over the next 73 years this couple
remained an old-fashioned love story I
fell in love with him practically at
first sight probably what Holman told my
mother about him
she was should have been the head of the
CIA she knew everything about him the
next morning but he's just a he's a very
giving his never once said no to me the
two exchanged love letters throughout
their relationship including one George
sent in 1943 while serving in World War
two they shared it on The Oprah Winfrey
Show I love you precious with all my
heart to know you love me
means my life how often have I thought
about the immeasurable joy that will be
ours someday how lucky our children will
be to have a mother like you
this was pretty good preview of coming
attractions I'll tell you very nice
thank you thank you
she'll feel the same way they were
married longer than any couple in
presidential history one of the reasons
I made the most important decision of my
life
to marry George Bush is because he made
me laugh
at times Barbara Bush pulled 40 points
higher than her husband and she used her
capital to support him you make me feel
wonderful but then I always feel
wonderful when I get to talk about the
strongest the most decent the most
caring the wisest yes and the healthiest
man I know there's six kids produce the
widest range of parental emotions
imaginable watching one son become
president thank you very much
another the governor of Florida and
burying a daughter Robin who died of
leukemia at the age of three through it
all papi and bar as they called each
other
celebrated and endured together the way
I describe it is they could be at a
dinner table and they can look at each
other and they're talking to one another
without saying a word that's what
happens when you're when you're in the
last Barbara Bush guarded her husband's
back kept his feet firmly planted on the
ground and even to the very end of their
long loving marriage made sure to hold
his hand George Bush George Bush wrote
that love letter to his then fiancee on
the same day that their engagement
announcement was published in the
newspaper and in it the former president
also writes spar you've made my life
full of everything I could ever dream up
my complete happiness should be a token
of my love for you that's a thought
that'll melt anybody on this morning as
we considered a life of art - you know
when we talk about public service this
is what that having covered politicians
this is what that means George Bush had
a life in public service and have you've
ever watched anybody you love get
attacked in public that hurts the person
who loves them the most she had to do
that through his whole career then do it
for two kids in public life and she had
to keep the emotional accounts for that
entire family and she was restrained
pretty much in public while going
through all of that emotional so she was
serving her country by serving her
family and doing it just like regular
old families do moving almost 30 times
keeping the house you know as well as
being
for that family that's what a dedication
to public service means when you
dedicate yourself to your family she was
criticized when going to Wellesley that
she hadn't had a career of her own but
in fact she was a career public servant
in so many ways that's right she did all
of this at a time that roles are
changing for women and she said that as
you said that that the women's movement
in a way made her feel inadequate
because that life of service she
dedicated to was being called and she
was fierce and she was fierce but had
she been the father and a man she would
have just been called strong and
protective she said you can attack me as
much as you want just don't attack my
husband or kids the Silver Fox